Watching.
We use the word logic and words derived
from that same Greek root logo center a
variety of ways.
You've probably said that someone was
being illogical because they were too
emotional or didn't agree with you.
You might've thought of logic as a way
of proving things or reasoning better.
I plan to dig a little deeper and talk
about logic is one basic way to approach
our use of language.
For starters,
that means I'd like to distinguish
between logic as a way of talking about
thinking,
especially reasoning and truth and logic
as a way of talking about language and
what goes into using language.
I don't mean to propose this division
as a hard and exception list rule,
but however you plan to use logic.
As long as you're communicating
with other humans,
you're basic starting point will be
logic as a way to analyze language,
but since the systems we
use to communicate analysis
are themselves languages,
that means we'll have to consider logic
itself as a language. This short series,
we'll introduce logic as a language.
More specifically,
I'll present logic as a formal language,
a formal,
not because it's more polite but because
it focuses on form instead of meaning
before getting into the basics.
Consider what I,
I will and will not cover in this series.
Um,
you will get to consider
logic as a language.
See how to translate into that language
and look at symbolic logic as a kind of
backbone model for the fuller
statements made in everyday language.
I won't spend time analyzing good or bad
arguments, you know, syllogisms informal,
informal fallacies and the like.
Um,
I won't discuss inductive
versus deductive reasoning. Uh,
and we'll consider admittedly
important questions like,
does logic underlie both
language in reality,
one of the various types of logics and
how do they relate to or differ from each
other or apply the logic of the language
of logic to any particular field.
On with the basics, I threw the
terms logic and language out at you.
I know those are abstract terms,
but think about learning a new language,
a language spoken in some foreign country.
If you reflect for a moment on
the components of that language,
you'll have to take on new sounds,
new parts of words,
the specific words used in that language,
the meaning of those new words and the
rules for constructing well-formed to
phrases and sentences.
One way to simplify all of this is
by trying to find some core concept.
We might imagine that speakers use
language to convey things to listeners.
For example,
when I tell you about a house,
you might think of something
very much like this,
so the word house acts
as a symbol for this.
Here we took words as our core concept
and said that words are symbols,
but it looks like words
aren't just symbols.
They're fixed symbols with
specific definitions. When
you parse the word house,
you related the word to a single concept.
The word house.
At other words act like
constant symbols or constants.
One key feature of these constants like
House dog and blue is that they have
semantic value there.
They're meaningful.
These meaningful constants,
constants can relate to one another
and a variety of ways to broaden basic
relationships.
Our intention and extension.
Intention refers to what a word connotes.
Other words commonly associated with
that word or other words that are
properties of that word.
This connotes house red and so on.
Extension is what a word denotes
it's definition or it's examples.
For example,
house extends to this.
Of course,
we don't just speak in single words.
We also make statements like the
houses red or fish can swim and those
statements are meaningful so we
would consider those symbols to.
So far it follows at those statements
would also work like Constance,
but now we're taking on so many symbols,
all kinds of things,
all kinds of sentences. We can say
about things. All of these are symbols.
It would be hard to count all of them,
let alone, let alone analyze all of them.
What if we could strip language
down to just the symbols?
That's the aim of symbolic logic.
We want a set of symbols that helps
us evaluate structure without getting
tethered in the meaning and the use.
We may still want constants,
but we'll definitely need symbols that
aren't so fixed since their meanings
wouldn't be fixed. These symbols would
vary, so they're called variables.
To make it easy on ourselves, we'll use
very simple symbols for variables like x.
We can use these variables for words.
This x can mean a house,
but it's not limited to that value.
It might mean a dog.
It might also represent
an entire statement.
This house is red or I'm speaking English.
These symbols will help with strip are
our language down and take a good look at
the structure. For variables. I
can use symbols like x, Y, andZ ,
four statements with some truth
value. It's common to use p. And Q.
These are all conventions.
Of course, in concrete cases,
you will want to use a symbol that helps
you make sense of the logical form,
say e,
when you're exclusively reading he
as the English language or English.
In this case,
you're using that symbol as an individual
constant and name with a specific
interpretation. Well, that's
background for the upcoming videos.
In the next lesson,
I'll talk about subjects and predicates.
I'll also use variables and constants
to take a look at the logic behind some
normal language sentences
using formal logic.